danielle
is with us in athens georgia hi danielle
how are you
hi dave i'm doing well how are you
better than i deserve what's up
i need your help settling a lively
marital discussion um my husband i've
been talking about for about a year
and he actually encouraged me to call in
because i've been very
dogged in what i think is the right
thing to do
you said your husband what for a year
say that again
we've just been discussing it for about
a year oh okay and he encouraged you to
call this show
yeah okay okay yeah and hi anthony glad
to hear from you too um
so broadly our question is should we
buy and flip a fixer-upper or
anthony's gonna love it pay off our
student loans
uh well you know what i'm gonna like we
actually know what both dave and i are
gonna like
but what's the argument i mean what what
are you saying daniel
would you like some context my husband
and i have been
we've been married for seven years okay
and
actually got to the money makeover as a
wedding and we've
always been dave ish i'm almost at eight
he's the oldest of six
there's nothing to fall back on if we
totally feel alive
so we've always been fairly conservative
in our spending
and had student loans and no credit card
debt
um but my master's is in non-profit
management
his is in social work so so we have to
be creative with how we fill our budget
so
in essence we bought our first house in
2015
it was like 82 thousand dollars it's
like 3 500
down payment and he renovated the whole
house himself
so we bought it for 82 put 14 or so into
it over two years
sold it when we had an 18 month old and
i was seven months pregnant
sold it for 128.5 and then took that
35 000 net profit put as a down payment
on our current house
okay so we want to be able to use his
skill set
um his dad built their one of his houses
when he was 12. he and his brothers can
all
tile and they've refinished floors and
built roofs right
and so he really wants to get into we're
in athens it's a college town he wants
to get
into rentals um i want to be completely
debt free
and very low risk before we consider
that how much student loans do
19 583 dollars
our net is about 70 and
mine fluctuates last year i was um
coaching a lot at a local boutique
fitness studio
and um we've always used his as the
foundation and then i kind of part-time
bring stuff in we have a three and a
five-year-old so we
my work juggles around so explain to me
why during the year you've been talking
about this you couldn't have already
paid off the student loan
excellent question dave we refinanced to
a 15 year with a cash out
in actually on march 15th of this year
which was two days before our county
locked down with the intent to pay off
the student loan immediately and because
everything locked down
we decided to give it six months while
there was a break on
student loan um interest rates and build
up
our emergency savings so we're out of
three months
now we didn't want to have only a
thousand dollars in the bank during
covid just in case
um because his job is pretty secure but
we've always done a lot of
so are you back to work accommodating
with my extern
i i am not there's no fitness
jobs okay so why while you so you get
enough cash out of the refinance to pay
off the student loan right
correct and you're still sitting on that
that's right dave okay and so while
you're sitting on this egg
he starts to go i want to buy a house
with it instead
he's been thinking that since about may
that was not the agreement when we
refinanced the house
well refinanced the house was we were
gonna pay off the student loan and the
only reason we didn't was coveted
right and so but while because covet hit
we sat on this egg and this egg's
starting to crack now
and he's starting to lose his mind and
go on to buy a house
yes that's accurate and what was he
still working during covet
yeah oh he's never quit never quit yet
so yeah
so he works in i.t for the university
and works remote right now so
he's his income solid but daniel
come on let me let me just let me help
you out this is this is anthony
i'm gonna be a more calmer version of
dave for you okay
uh i want you to get to get the money
and go pay off the super lows
i mean just just just just get the money
go pay off the student loans
and then once you pay off the student
loans go back to the three months
then after the three months then i mean
we're just going to work the baby steps
you know i think a lot of people right
now just are getting like
money hungry oh i can i can use my
skills to make more money
and that's fine i want you to make more
money dave
we both want to make more money but do
it on a solid foundation so
what does he do for a living now
he went back to his bachelor's he's in
it
for uga how many hours a week should
work program software
he's 40 hours a week salary perfect
benefit perfect okay so
let me let me tell you i got a buddy of
mine that's good with laying tile
and putting up trim and doing carpentry
work and fixing a gutter
start a little remodel business and last
year he made 300 000
profit oh man so these are skills that
are valuable i'm not sure your husband
necessarily wants to leave the i.t
field but i think on the weekend he
could build some decks
and do some other stuff and he can make
more money doing that than he can
screwing around and flipping houses and
bankrupting you people
thank you on someone else's dime because
they're in and they're just hello
no risk they just write you checks yeah
for your work is my favorite phrase and
we get to use
and we get to use our skill
that mom and or the dad taught me which
is a wonderful skill my dad taught me to
swing a hammer too it's a wonderful
thing to be able to
pick up a screwdriver and know which end
works you know and so it's a good thing
i'm glad he has that skill
but it is it's leading you guys down a
bad path you need to write a check pay
off the student loans as soon as you
talk to him tonight i don't want you to
hide it from him but
anthony's advice is exactly correct
interesting discussion it is so it's
almost as if you're heading in the right
direction
and if you pause instead of going ahead
and doing what you're supposed to do
it gives you the opportunity to do
stupid yes that was a problem you could
almost take you could all you know
you're going down the interstate and you
let your foot off the gas
and the car starts drifting towards the
exit yes and and
exit says land is stupid right right
and that that was the interesting thing
and i've done that before dave you know
i
i see you know i'm gonna do this then
when i get it actually in my hands
yeah you look at that pile of money i'm
like ooh
you look maybe i'm gonna go over here
rather than going over the when when
sometimes just best don't even see it
get it
and do exactly what you was gonna do
with it execute
your plan yep develop your plan execute
your plan and uh the only now they did
have a valid reason for tapping the
brakes because of covet okay i'd have to
argue that
but it is interesting that when you have
a moment to think about it
yeah i've done that too yeah i i that's
what i could relate to i thought
you know when if i just would go ahead
and do what the flip i'm supposed to do
instead of stopping and thinking about
it
it really because when i think about it
when i get done sometimes
just that that's exactly what happened
there yeah so interesting very
interesting discussion now we gotta say
this to dave now
when you're going into your emergency
fund you do want to stop and think and
make sure that it is emergency so we're
not telling people don't think
but we're saying when you say you're
going to do something do it well i
you know i've got i'm executing on a
plan
and the next step of the plan is x and
if you pause and start
gazing at that pot of gold yes your eyes
will cross
yes and you'll go into a gold coma
absolutely yeah it's what that's what
happens and
that that's very interesting that and
they did it for the right reasons
because they should have paused because
of covet yeah i don't disagree with that
you didn't have a thousand dollars in
the bank
that was her point and that follows what
we were teaching people right in the
middle of
it yeah you know just calm down you know
sit pause you don't have to do a bunch
of moves right now
however it is also an interesting
principle
that um a lot here's what i'm trying to
say
but sometimes we're over think it
sometimes we overthink it james we
overthink
how do you how do you lose weight you
eat less
and you work out you know what makes you
look thinner than wearing black being
thinner